he was an American blues singer
songwriter and guitarist he was inducted
into the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame in
1987 he's considered one of the most
influential blues musicians of all time
earning the nickname the king of blues
he's BB King and hear his top ten rules
for success what do you want to do with
your music and with your singing play
the best that I can
reached his many people is again as many
countries other words I'd like the whole
world to be able to hear BB King sing
and play the blues
well practice is something that we think
is something you should do daily anyway
because I'm lazy now don't but generally
you you kind of think for example I know
that the North Sea Jazz Festival people
used to hear in various types of music
so when I come out I try to do the best
that I can do of my kind of music
Phoebe do you still practice yes yes I
do not not nearly enough but I play
every night practically at least four or
five nights a week and I'd practice but
my practice and it's not what it should
be other words to really just get down
and play this scales on something once
or twice a week hmm but by me playing
every night usually I'm always running
into something of accidentally falling
into something that I hadn't heard
before and then you go back and look for
it later on when you do practice what do
you work on do you have any specific
exercises there my exercises usually
it's the scales mostly mostly that and
just all over the neck of the guitar
because if I keep doing it I usually
will hear and you start the plan will
you keep hearing you hear things that
you can play with you know it's
something like that that's what I keep
doing until a finished say stuff that
feeling on the guitar that that singing
string that we went was afraid you used
for it before twinkling it this is your
own this is this is your contribution I
think so I've I think it is as I've
heard so many guys since I started
playing sound that way and I don't
remember ever hearing about it before
that not before that about 200 about 250
to 275 concerts per year sometimes that
mean you might do two in one day
I am 69 I'll be 70 in September the 16th
if I live that long
and I find the energy meeting people
like yourselves I enjoy people I love to
play see people happy I love to see them
dance see them enjoy themselves that's
energy for man it's education I get a
chance to learn out of st. merci
beaucoup I don't speak French but
Lucille does music is a universal
language and I believe that because it's
been many times I've heard great
musicians like Django Reinhardt
I love never ham speak English but he
speaks it with it guitar so I think
music is a universal language that we
can I believe communicate with anyone
well yes I believe I do I don't want to
stick my neck out there but I think so
but I'm I'm grateful that some of them
seem to like me I'm I'm grateful because
to me it seemed to open a few doors for
us that seemed like that was never gonna
be open and we're glad when people like
Mike and the rest of the fellows will
take up some of the things we do we're
very happy because I until the days of
rock and roll a lot of times a lot of
the places we they just wouldn't accept
us I'm not I'm not speaking racially and
I'm just talking about the people as a
whole that just wouldn't accept us in
some of the places that the doors open
now that you can go into because of
people like Mike Elvis Presley the
Beatles Fats Domino people like that
helped us out quite a bit well I think
like this the management or Newport Club
wouldn't want me if they couldn't have
people that wanted to see me so I try my
best to let the audience know that I
appreciate appreciate them and their
appearance here with me or their support
if you will by and letting them know
that I love them too I've been around
some artists been around some places
even once the audience I never forget
once I was in Chicago I won't mention
the club I was in Chicago and the
management had been advertising to get
people to come get people to come so
people were there so when the show was
over some guy got up and said well you
don't have to go home but you got to
live here that made me angry I got very
angry very angry I said that he could
say you know folks we got to close you
know that old stuff about you don't
to go home but you got to leave here he
didn't say that when he's trying to get
him to come in so I wasn't happy about
that at all so you don't get that here
sure there are curfews in some places
some place you have to close at a
particular time the audience understands
that so if you tell them you're gonna
have a few that may grumble but the
majority of the people are right with
you in this sensible they know that if
you don't close down maybe lose your
license um so if you say folks sorry the
time is now we have to cut it off
it's a curfew time and most of the
majority of the people will walk out
they will go what is for you the the
characteristics of a good melody
something that seemed to stay with you
sometimes you wake up mornings and you
go to wash your face and you still hear
this something in your head you walk out
and all of a sudden you're whistling
something that stays with you
that's a good melody that haunts you
are you still getting better as a
guitarist I hope I am I hope so I can't
always tell because I still can't play
like I want to play
it's a lot of young guitars have new
ways of playing and they to me
of what's going on today while people
still want to see you I'm glad oh okay
am I glad
yeah
so I was going to Montgomery to play
called the promoter I said I broke down
I said I don't know how long it's gonna
take to fix it and it was about 2:30 3
o'clock in the evening then I said but
I'm pretty sure that we'll be late when
we get that heat that's all right beat
come on up there now you should come on
come on
so sure enough we were late when the bus
got ready and we went on up there when
we got there you it that we had
something you called it
you don't hear much about them today
honorees so the army you started from
the ground floor and you had to walk
about 10 or 15 stairs and there was a
platform like it so that's what he was
set to collect his tickets in the money
and then you go about 10 or 15 more
flows and there's the the dance hall ok
so when I got there I said well we made
it
he's yeah but you can turn around go
back now because I know pay you're gonna
be justly just oh you won't be late easy
well I have AZ tell Rocco but I said
well since I'm here I have a you know a
thing about being late I have a thing
about you know standing up to people I
said let me go on I'm play so okay and
going up in one but I know pay us okay
so we went on upstairs when we got on
the dance floor and it was just people
was just look like that packed in that
well sure would like to have some of
that money so we can upset and we
started the plan and the people you know
you couldn't buy liquor big care you
what they called a brown bag carry okay
your bottle with you or at the Armory
they had places where you can keep your
bowels
well we got the plane and people started
taking a Yaqui dr. everything was going
to it so after I played about two or
three peat pieces you know and everybody
was fired up man I said ladies and
gentlemen so you know this is OB and I
have never stood you up
no B you always come in times yeah I
well I got something I'm sad to tell you
but when I came upstairs the boss told
me when one payment
everybody got quiet
what so no he said he wasn't gonna pay
me and now I ain't telling you what to
do but I feel that if I'm a freak he
should be able to listen free you know
San Diego favor and I love you a plan
hey y'all check on your money boy
I look at later the money went one way
and I dude whatever thank you so much
for watching I made this video because
Arun Kumar asked me to so if there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do I'd
also love to know which of BB King's top
ten rules had the greatest impact on you
leave it in the comments and I'll join
in the discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon
well everybody that looks at me now cuz
usually I when I'm talking about my
guitars always Lucille so mm-hm and they
look at me like that
mm-hm and then I tell them that how I
gave the name Lucille to my guitar we
were playing out near place called twist
Arkansas twist Arkansas hmm okay and
they had a place for you to dance like
over here uh-huh
and you eat over here and that's where I
stayed at most times when I was no stage
they had a small stage you know so
smaller than this and I would go in and
I would start to play and eat eat and
play sounds good to me
and two guys started fighting they do
quite a bit of that in Mississippi
Louisiana and Arkansas near the small
joints for the gamble then when these
guys started playing sin winter they had
a big pail sitting in the middle of the
floor and one knocked other one over on
this container and when he did well it
spilled on the floor and when he spilled
on the floor everybody started running
out including me you know forgot my
guitar and never done it before and
never have did it since then but I went
back in and got my guitar and I almost
lost my life trying to save it and
that's when I named my guitar Lucille
because these two guys I learned was
fighting about a lady that worked in the
place where that cooked the food and I
named my guitar Lucille to remind me
never to do that again yeah
we almost lost your life going back in
to get you you might yeah and you named
it Lucy onus stuck all these years
that's all